الحمد لله حق حمده
والصلاه والسلام على من لا نبي من بعده
واعلموا عباد الله
ان الله تعالى امرنا بامر بدا فيه بنفسه
وثنى بملائكه
قدسه
وثلث بالمؤمنين من عالمي جنه وانسه
وقال تعالى قولا كريما
تعظيما لقدر نبينا
وتفهيما لنا وتعليما
وتفخيما له صلى الله عليه وسلم وتعظيما
ان الله وملائكته
يصلون على النبي
يا ايها الذين امنوا صلوا عليه وسلموا
تسليما
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك
واكرم وانعم وتحنن وتعطف
على سيدنا محمد طب القلوب ودوائها
وعافيه الابدان وشفائها
ونور الابصار وضيائها
وعلى اله وصحبه وسلم تسليما كثيرا كثيرا
اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى ال سيدنا
محمد كما صليت على سيدنا ابراهيم وعلى ال
سيدنا ابراهيم انك حميد مجيد وبارك بارك
على سيدنا محمد وعلى ال سيدنا محمد كما
باركت على سيدنا ابراهيم وعلى ال سيدنا
ابراهيم في العالمين انك حميد مجيد مكمل
علوم الاولين والاخرين
مولانا ومولى الثقلين ابي القاسم ابي
الزهراء محمد فيا ايها الراجون شفاعته
اكثروا من الصلاه والتسليم عليه فان
صلاتكم نور على الصراط حين تمرون عليه
الله
ادم
نوح
ابراهيم
عمران
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ادم عليه السلام
الله سبحانه وتعالى تعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ادم عليه السلام ذا فكا
بروت نوح عليه السلام
[Silence]
‏FL
the second is
life
heaven
to those
life
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
ابراهيم
‏was
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه واله وصحبه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
was
the
wasad
people
is الله
[Silence]
اف عمران السوره
وال عمران
على العالمين
اف عمران
ذا ف موسى
هارون
الله سبحانه وتعالى
المن والسلوى
عمران
مريم
عيسى عليه السلام
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
محمد صلى الله عليه
‏So
the darkness of worshipping the created
and move of the hor of worshing the
creator
that we move from injustice and blad
to peace
jce and security
‏un
[Silence]
‏and honesty
and tru
and from this
with divine
[Silence]
ب
الله سبحانه وتعالى
قريش
[Silence]
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
‏our
mercy of the
was not to any other prop عليه الصلاه
والسلام
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
واعلي كلمتي الحق والدين
اللهم اغفر لنا وارحمنا وتب علينا وسامحنا
واختم يا ربنا بالصالحات اعمالنا اللهم
اختم لنا بالصالحات يا رب العالمين اللهم
فرج هم المهمومين ونفس كرب المكروبين
اللهم اشف مرضى المسلمين اللهم اشف مرضى
المسلمين ومن اوصانا بالدعاء يا رب
العالمين انت اعلم منا بذكر اسمهم يا اكرم
الاكرمين يا ذا الجلال والاكرام اللهم
اللهم فرج عن اخواننا المسلمين في كل مكان
اللهم احقن دماء المسلمين في كل مكان
اللهم فرج همنا ونفس كربنا وحقق امانينا
اللهم انا نسالك ونتوجه اليك في هذه
الساعه المباركه ان تؤلف بين قلوبنا اللهم
وان ترحم صغيرنا اللهم
وفق قنا لما تحب وترضى اللهم واجعلنا على
منهج الكتاب والسنه برحمه منك يا ارحم
الراحمين سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين ان الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان
وايتاء ذي القربى وينهى عن الفحشاء
والمنكر والبغي يعظكم لعلكم تذكرون
واقم ‏S